Y CERTAINLY CAN UNDERSTAND
THAT D
KYIV.
STAY SAFE OVER THERE
TO YOU.
>>> I WANT TO
CORRESPONDENT SAZEM  TERRO
AT AN UNPRECEDENTED LEVEL.
WHAT ARE YOU LEARNAB
SITUATION THERE NOW?
>> Reporter: WELL,T THRUSSIA SA
THEY SEI TO PREVEN
THEY'RE EXPLNGAIONBEING IN THE .
THE
FOR MANY.
RE CURRENTLY T
CONTROL OF THE RSI MILITARY.STA
THNERG
AUTHORITY, IS OKAY.
THERE HAS BEO LE
IT ITIONING NORM.
THE  NSHT CHANGE
THOUGH WITH THE PEOPLE WHO ARE
BEING LDE RUSSIANS THERE IAND,
BEFORE THE CONTROLLL TS
INTO RUSSIAN HANDS.
QUITE  EXTRAORDINARY EXCTHAT I'
THINK WE'VE GOT AND WE CAN
YOU AND IFE CAN RU AN-- SIMULTA
MOMENT WHEN THE FATE
PLANET BOILS DOWN TO AANGEBEEE
NUCLEAR POR ATMEN SHOOTING AT IT
ING
SECURITY OF THE
WHOLE
THE WORK OTHORGANS
THE ZAPORIZH STATION MAY BE
DISRUPTED.
IT WILL BE IMPOSSIBLE FOR US TO
OES , YOU'RE ENDANGERING
THSE
D.
ATTENTIO SHOOTING AT THE N
HAZARDOULITY